one of the questions that I love that I
often get asked is I know that a company
can have a why an organization can have
a why does that mean my family as a why
and the answer is of course any
individual has a why and a group of
individuals that come together then that
collective is also a why just like the
organization just like the company
absolutely a family has a why the family
has founders mom and dad and the family
has employees the kids and there are
certain values that we want to pass on
to our kids how we do things around here
this is how we do things in this
household absolutely there's a
combination and that why is that
beautiful overlap between mom and dad
and it's the combination of their why's
that give the family their why and I've
heard stories of some families who once
they've articulated their family why
they've actually had it written on the
plaque and they hang it on the wall for
all the kids and all the family to see
to remind everybody why this family
exists why we do we do and what we care
about and what we believe how we do
things and the values that we see
important and the kids are given all
kinds of bonuses and rewards for
upholding those values so absolutely as
a family a family has a why and the way
you come at it is the exact same same
way you come at it for any group of
people or organization